[Music]  a special groundbreaking in henderson  today aristocrat gaming officially  putting shovels in the ground at the  site of its new manufacturing facility  it is going up near the m resort south  of saint rose parkway that massive  facility will be where slot machines are  made before being sent thousands of  miles away  so we manufacture out of this facility  and we ship product all over the world  we obviously support the u.s  and north american market we also ship  into latin america to the european  countries as well and then often down  into our australian and macau properties  as well  that facility is expected to be complete  by fall of next year